so Mexico has descended into total chaos
I mean Mexico of course has been in a
state of chaos for four decades now but
descended further I suppose is what I
mean the catalyst for this this recent
wave of anarchy and violence was the
Mexican government capturing a video
Guzman Lopez who is one of the most
powerful drug lords in the country also
the son of El Chapo who recently was
arrested well arrested for the third or
fourth time after escaping each time now
he's in federal prison in maximum
maximum security
so Mexican government they captured this
guy in the northern Mexican city of
Culiacan hopefully I'm pronouncing that
right but probably not
well what led up to this well the
immediate events leading up to this
anyway apparently some drug gang guys
started from it from a house started
firing on two police in the city of
Culiacan police went into the house they
surrounded it they found Guzman there
and then they successfully captured him
which is a very impressive
accomplishment that they've got like I
said one of the most powerful drug lords
in the country well because this is
someone who you know wanted to stay in
the family business and and so he's a
drug lord as well but then the cartel
retaliated full force and the city
turned into a war zone and I'm gonna
play for you just a few of the the
sights and sounds out of Mexico over the
last 24 hours to give you a feel of what
it's been like
so here's we'll start with this you
can't see much but you can hear it
so again sounds sounds like a war zone
listen to this
[Music]
and this video has been circulating a
lot on social media you see gunmen
patrolling the streets of the city as if
they've taken over which they basically
have and then here's here's what it
looked here's what it look like we say
it was a war zone here's what it looked
like last night
okay now we get to the really sad
pitiful terrifying part which is that
the government decided to release the
drug lord they released him they
arrested him the cartel showed up
started shooting everybody and the
government said okay you can have him
back never mind and so the cartel wins
this is the kind of thing that happens
in a failed state where you no longer
have any real system of government it's
just it's a free-for-all which is what
it is the rule of law is completely
broken down and criminals are running
the show and that's the situation in
Mexico has been for a long time it's
only getting worse and that leads me to
this hey maybe actually the wall is a
good idea
I don't know we when you see videos what
I wanted to play some that footage for
you when you see that footage and you
think that's what's going on directly
south of our border that's what's
happening in the country that is our
directly to the south of us and you
think well maybe building a wall on the
southern border
makes a lot of sense when you've got a
crime riddled cartel infested failed
state where gunmen patrol the streets
with machine guns directly to the south
of you you build a lot wall it's not
going to solve all the problems but it
makes sense to do that
might be a good plan it would be nice if
we actually did it because we haven't
yet the wall has not been built we have
Trump has replaced some of the existing
fence with nicer fence so we've done
that but that is not quite the big
beautiful wall with the one nice
beautiful door that we were promised I
would like the big wall with the big
door I or maybe no door at all in fact
would be it would be even better but we
haven't gotten that yet there really is
no argument against this what are the
arguments against building the wall
people have not people have been arguing
against it for years and I don't know
what the argument actually is because
there isn't one
it's it's emotion the argument is
emotion it's well it makes me feel weird
to have a wall down there makes me feel
claustrophobic kind of closed in that's
not an R
and so we should just build the wall in
conclusion all right let's talk about
this case really said concerning case
especially considering the timing we
have now another situation of a police
officer shooting an innocent person in
their own home we're all familiar with
the Amber Geiger case that's the Dallas
cop who went into a man's apartment last
year shot him dead
said she thought was she thought it was
her apartment she was in the wrong
apartment
and rather than try to figure out what's
going on or or think maybe I made a
mistake she just decided to shoot the
guy well now she's going to jail for ten
years only a week or so maybe two weeks
after that verdict and since that
sentencing was passed down we've got
something eerily similar in the same
general geographic area though with a
few key differences in this case officer
Aaron Dean Fort Worth officer so like I
said very close to where the Dallas
shooting happened he's shot and killed
at to Tiana
Jefferson in her home in her home at
2:00 in the morning a few days ago she
was entirely innocent did nothing wrong
she was apparently in her house staying
up late with her nephew playing video
games next thing you know she's dead at
the hands a police officer on the job in
some ways this case is even worse than
the Amber guide your thing because this
guy was on the job in some ways it makes
it even worse although I guess it's
suppose it's hard to rank it when you've
got innocent people being gunned down by
the government agents that are supposed
to be protecting them it's hard to rank
which is worse than that they're all
terrible what led up to it well
obviously there's going to be an
investigation more facts will come out
Dean was arrested charged with murder so
there's going to be we don't know
everything yet and all these things are
gonna come out but we do know enough to
say I think that Jefferson certainly did
not deserve to be shot that's for damn
sure we can say that much so what led up
to it a neighbor of Jefferson noticed
that her door had been left open and it
was late at night so the neighbor was
concerned he's just trying to be a good
neighbor
and think about how this they did an
interview with them with the neighbor
and and he was devastated and said he
felt like it was his fault partly his
fault which of course it's not his fault
at all he was he was being a he's being
a good neighbor how was he supposed to
know the police were gonna show up and
shoot and shoot the woman but he saw the
door open and he was a little bit
concerned so he called a non-emergency
number as I understand it and said hey
my neighbor's doors been left open she
doesn't usually leave it open not sure
what's going on can you sense I want to
check it out I'm paraphrasing but that
was the vibe that's generally what he
said so Dean and his partner got the
call they are told that it's an open
structure so it's an open structure call
which and anyone with a law enforcement
experience right now you can probably
offer more of an insight into what an
open structure call is and so you can
email me with that I'd be interested but
as I understand it an open structure
call is kind of a vague nonspecific
thing but it does mean that it could be
a burglary so open structure as in
there's a structure that's someone left
open who knows why could be bad could be
neutral who knows so Dean and his
partner show up they see the door open
they see the the lights on in the house
apparently they see you know toys and
things around because there's a there's
a kid there rather than go up to the
door
rather than announce themselves maybe
ring the doorbell or shout into the door
hey is everything okay in there rather
than doing anything like that they sneak
around back in a poorly lit part of the
yard and they try to peer through a
window now Jefferson inside try to try
to put yourself in her shoes it's two
o'clock in the morning she's minding her
own business she hears someone outside
her house in her yard right near the
window and so she gets scared you know
understandably so and she pulls a gun
out of her purse
keep in mind this is happening through a
window okay so she's in her room
here's someone outside the window window
is as I understand it closed there's a
glare nobody can really see exactly
what's happening with what's going on
which means that Jefferson's actions are
totally warranted again she's in her
house she knows it so there's somebody
in her yard she has every right to
assume that they mean her harm she pulls
a gun totally an appropriate response
but the officer on the other hand also
doesn't know exactly what's going on
because he can't see which means that
his actions are completely unwarranted
because he has his gun out and he yells
apparently put your hands up show me
your hands and seconds later he opens
fire through the window kills her now
he's charged with murder and that put
your hands up thing first of all I'm not
sure that the guy ever announced himself
as a police officer so the quote that I
saw in the media was put your hands up
show me your hands not police put your
hands up show me your hands
so when someone starts showing you
wouldn't you're in your house in the
middle of the night minding a business
business and all of a sudden you hear
someone shouting at you put your hands
up you you again have every right to
assume they mean you harm and you were
under no obligation to obey that order
you know who the hell this is or what
they want
you're not gonna say oh he wants to blow
my hands up I guess I'll do it
in but but here's the thing even if she
knew that it was a police officer which
we have no reason to think she did know
that but even if she did hypothetically
know that it was a police officer she
still did nothing wrong and having her
gun she has every right to defend
herself in her own home police officers
don't have the right to just come to
your home and shoot you they aren't gods
they aren't Kings they aren't they they
are supposed to have laws they obey then
there are laws against that and this is
where the gun some this is where some
gun rights advocates seem to take their
I off the ball a little bit because we
hear all the time from gun-rights people
that you know we we need guns not just
to protect ourselves from burglars and
bad guys but to protect ourselves from
the government and in fact we hear from
gun rights people I am a gun rights
person I say this myself all the time
that this is the Second Amendment is not
just or even primarily about protecting
yourself from fellow citizens it's about
being able to protect yourself from the
government government yet many of those
same people would say that if an agent
of the government comes with a gun
no matter the context no matter anything
you have to obey everything they say
even in your own home and if you don't
and you get shot it's your fault and
this is what confuses me so what the
hell happen to the Second Amendment
protecting us from tyranny it just
really confuses me when these people who
always are going on about how we need
the Second Amendment protect us from the
government yet there are the same people
to say cops tell you to do something
does it matter what it is in what
context where you are you do everything
doesn't matter and if you if you disobey
even a little bit and get killed it's
your fault I am NOT making a straw man
I'm not exaggerating that really is the
position that a lot of people
unfortunately on the right have not
everybody but I've had this conversation
before I've gotten emails that really is
how a lot of people feel if you disobey
the police officers it doesn't matter
any dis a l'heure to to follow orders
you get shot your fault it's done it's
kind of amazing you know that people can
abandon their their support for Liberty
at the drop of a hat in order to in
favor of their more statist impulses but
anyway I think hopefully we can all
agree that she had every right to pull a
gun and defend herself in this case and
he had no right to fire blindly through
a window into a woman's home and kill
her in her own home I would hope that's
not controversial
the crush the question that's raised
though is why do these things happen yes
we should stipulate as always that the
majority of cops are good competent they
aren't going around shooting innocent
people they aren't shooting through
windows they aren't going into guys
apartments and shooting them this is
obviously a small minority of cases of
course but we all see the news
we know these kinds of cases do happen
they happen way too often one time is
too often and they've happened a lot
more than once I think we could agree so
we don't need to get into a we don't
need to get into a contest or or exactly
how many the point is it happens too
much hopefully we can agree with that
where people are needlessly killed in
situations where the officer involved
obviously had other options not
happening the majority of cases but it
does happen why well it of course has
been pointed out that the that Jefferson
was black the officers white just as
Geiger is white and her victim was black
so the racial angle has been highlighted
I would say exploited by the media which
we knew was going to happen I don't
think race had anything to do with this
whatsoever in fact part of the outrage
here is that the officers in both of
these particular cases couldn't even
really see who it was they couldn't see
what they were doing which is which is
why partly why they shot because they
were scared and that's also what makes
it so outrageous and wrong but I don't
think there's any it's we have no idea
if if the officer in this case could
even see Jefferson just tell anything
about her the same for the victim in in
the amber Geiger case so I don't think
that race really anything to do with it
I think I mean I'm in fact I'm an
agreement with the Dallas Morning News
today they had an article saying that
Jefferson's death is a result first of
all of an officer who didn't follow
proper procedure because none of that
was proper procedure he didn't announce
himself he didn't go to the door
first snuck around back in the dark
shooting through a window that's just
not what you do but second it also has
to do with police training that
emphasizes the safety of the officer
over the safety of the community and
this is something that I've noticed for
a while now I've commented on it before
people get upset when I talk about it
but it's true we we hear all the time
every time a questionable shooting
happens and this this shooting we're
talking about now is not questionable
this is a bad shoot period but
completely wrong and outrageous but but
anytime there's a bad shoot or a
questionable one what we hear from
apologists for the cops is that well
look they can't take any chances they're
protecting themselves that's what we
hear okay but maybe they should take a
little bit of a chance because not
taking a chance is just another way of
saying shoot a civilian just to be safe
even if it's not strictly speaking
necessary shoot him just to be safe
shoot first ask questions later so not
taking a chance is really saying not
giving the civilian a chance think of
that horrible case in Arizona that we
talked about a couple years ago of a
cops gunning a guy down in this case it
was a white guy again not the race
matters but they gun this guy down in in
in the middle of a hallway in a hotel
while he was crawling on his hands and
knees literally begging for his life and
you had three cops in a hallway guns
trained on this guy while he's crawling
on the ground on his hands and knees and
they shot him and killed him and even in
that case which to me was so obviously
outrageous and wrong and was murder
what I heard from apologist was well hey
you know he had it coming because he
reached he reached for his he reached
for his waistband he could've been go
for a gun and yes he did reach for his
waistband best because his pants were
falling down and he was trying to
preserve a little bit of his dignity he
was already on the ground crying begging
for his life while these two though
these three agents of the state are
shouting at him giving him contradictory
conflicting orders it don't make any
sense his pants are falling down so it
reflexively he goes to pull up his pants
yeah which which to me seems perfectly
reasonable and so they shoot him dead
now no you can say 12 is he could have
but he could have been going for a gun
could have been can't take any chances
well okay but number one you can really
probably see pretty well he doesn't have
a gun number two you can tell that he's
trying to cooperate with you he is
totally submissive it couldn't be any
more submissive number three even if on
some off chance he really did have a gun
hidden in his basketball shorts and he
really was going for that gun well he is
on his hands and knees you are standing
five feet away from him with your guns
already trained on him there's three of
you you're in a 10-foot wide hallway
even if he does grab a gun on that off
chance you'll be able to shoot him
before he can get a shot off at you
unless you're the worst shots in the
world unless you are unless you are
unless you totally skipped all that
whole part of police training that all
three of you would somehow miss this guy
in a 10-foot wide hallway when he's on
his grant on the ground hands and knees
so even if he went for it so you have to
think what are the chances
percentage-wise what are the chances
that he actually was going for a gun and
not just trying to pulls pants up very
small percentage even if he has a gun
what are the chances that he could
actually do any damage to you before you
get a chance to just pull you cuz he
used to grab his gun bring it up before
you just do this with your fingers so
overall percentage-wise
what was the percentage chance that
these officers would have been
at all physically harmed by this guy I
don't know obviously any percentage we
put on it is basically arbitrary but we
it's a small percentage 1% point zero
five percent very small this idea that
police have to protect themselves at any
cost even the cost of killing innocent
people just to be on the safe side is to
me the antithesis of what cops are
supposed to do their job is to protect
the community you don't protect the
community by shooting at it oh it's easy
for you to say that mad so easy for you
to say while you're sitting yeah you
know it is easy for me to say you're
right it is totally easy for me to say
but I didn't sign up for that job though
so to say it's easy for me to say ok I I
didn't sign up for it that's not the job
I signed up to do if you signed up to do
a job I think we can expect you to do it
without killing P innocent people I
think I don't think that's much too much
to ask just like if we talk about
negligence among medical professionals
well it's really easy for you to say if
you're not a surgeon that that surgeon
should have been negligent during a
surgery and killed someone really easy
for you to say you don't know anything
about being a surgeon you've never been
in that situation you don't understand
how high pressure and high stress it is
it so is easy for you to say sitting
there on your butt eating Cheetos saying
oh that's that surgeons should have done
that yeah it's really easy for you to
say but you aren't the one who signed up
for the job of being a surgeon you're
not the one getting paid to do it you
don't get any of the perks and the
respect that comes with that job because
you don't do it in a society we expect
the people who sign up for a particular
job to do that job and in fact as
citizens especially when the job is
something that has to do with the state
and government and authority as citizens
in a supposedly free country we have
every right to expect and demand that
you do that job without killing innocent
people
this idea that the you know we as
citizens should just sit here silently
and submissively because oh well you
know we we weren't the ones doing the
job that's not how it works they're
supposed to protect and serve us they're
supposed to work for us we pay their
with yeah I don't do the job I pay that
for that job though
so the job of the police officers serve
and protect the community and it seems
to me that the emphasis should be on
that over protecting you know for a
police officer the emphasis should be on
protecting the community over protecting
himself now that doesn't mean that he
should have to charge into gunfire
unarmed or that he should have to be
suicidal or do anything that is reckless
or put himself in harm's way for for for
you know reckless reasons I'm not saying
that I'm just saying that like hey if
there's a 95% chance that this person is
not a threat and a 5% chance that they
are yeah shooting them just in case will
make you safer but maybe don't right I
guess that's the way that the way that I
would look at it and they're so you know
we could go on and on with examples
Tamir rice another classic example
twelve-year-old child shot and killed by
police officer yet yet he had a fake toy
gun and yet again you heard you hear
from apologists that well hey they
didn't know it was fake and and you know
he he could have been a threat so they
just shot him alright again though what
are the chances that the twelve-year-old
kid is playing with a real gun on the
playground not impossible and in some
parts of the country that chance is
going to be much higher than you would
like it to be it's certainly not a 90
percent chance you know what are the
chances it's a child with a gun on a
playground what are the chances that
it's a real gun versus a fake gun I mean
at most you can do fifty-fifty but it's
probably not even that it's probably
more like 70/30 90/10 I don't know and
then even if it is a real gun what are
the chances that this child will be able
to get off a shot at you you the trained
law enforcement officer before you are
able to neutralize that threat so in
that case I think the cops should have
taken the chance and not killed a child
even if it meant that they were putting
themselves in harm's way a little bit
because it is just a little bit but when
it's a choice between putting myself in
harm's way a little bit or shooting and
killing a child probably you want to put
yourself in harm's way shouldn't we
expect that of our law enforcement
officers I mean isn't that isn't that
why we say these people are heroes they
is it's because they put themselves in
hard well if we're also saying well no
don't put yourself in harm's way just
kill everybody just in case that was
just not right okay a couple other
things there's an article in The
Guardian not going to spend much time on
this but an article in The Guardian that
says the the the headline is you don't
have to settle the joy of living and
dying alone and then it says data
confirms more women have realized there
are far worse things than dying alone
which is bad news for the patriarchy and
this whole article is about the how
wonderful and joyful it actually is to
live alone and not have a family and and
all of these things when I when I read
this article which is obviously just
something it's it's more sad than
anything this is obviously written by
someone who themselves is alone and
lonely not capable of forging a
meaningful relationship and that's how
they ended up alone like this because
that's really if you end up alone in
life there are only a few ways to end up
alone totally alone
one is through tragedy and people around
you have died or something which is
terrible that's not what we're talking
about here
or you could maybe you go into is it
could be monastic you're going into
religious life and taking a vow of
celibacy okay that's that's perfectly
wonderful but then if it's not one of
those options and you end up alone in
life probably it's because you are not
capable of forming human relationships
because you are a selfish miserable
narcissistic person and I think that's
the category we're talking about with an
article like this and that is the
category that some feminists advocate
and celebrate your life is all about you
don't worry about anybody else just be a
miserable selfish jerk they don't say
that part but that's implied it reminded
me when I was reading this article
reminded me of a great quote from well
from that that I saw in the movie into
the wild but it was actually it's a true
story yet if you've never seen that
movie I think it's a great movie about
Christopher McCandless who's the guy who
abandoned the society decided to go on
this journey of self-discovery and and
burned his social security card and his
license and was set off across the
country on this huge adventure ended up
in Alaska by himself and he ends up
getting trapped up there in Alaska and
the wilderness can't get out and he ends
up essentially starving to death and he
dies and this really happened to me a
movie about it but but right before he
died he wrote in a book in one of his
journals he wrote happiness is only real
when shared which is I think a really
powerful especially when you consider
what Heath went through to go through
come to this realization where he was
out searching for happiness and
fulfilment but doing it completely alone
and then he died out there alone
and what he realized is okay this is
this is this is great that I can find my
own fulfillment but I don't have anyone
to share it with it's just me and this
is not how people man is not meant to be
alone we're telling the Bible and that's
true and that's what it comes down to
for everyone you know the fact is
when you see older people who are alone
now because they've alienated everyone
in their life and again there are there
are older people who are alone for other
reasons that are not their fault but
there are there are some who are alone
now because they've alienated everyone
because they've been selfish miserable
people their entire lives and no one
wants it their their kids don't anything
to do with them their spouses have all
left them their multiple spouses have
left them and now they're alone these
are not happy people that is not a
recipe for happiness that's the
definition of unhappiness that is the
picture the illustration of unhappiness
because I think when it comes down to it
we it's it's a it's part of our nature
you know it's in our nature we are not
capable of being truly happy if we are
completely and totally alone which is
why in fact even in those monastic
traditions even where someone's in a
religious life and they take a vow of
celibacy and they don't have a
biological family they're still not
alone they still are in a community and
that community becomes their family too
becomes very important to them but as
people we are not Kate you cannot just
live completely alone you need people
happiness is a shared experience finally
oh well there was this headline in the
Washington Post it says new study
according to a new study
excessive brain activity is linked to a
shorter life which all I can say is this
is great news for Alexandra occasio
Cortez that's all I had I just had that
one joke I've nothing else to say about
that study didn't even read it ok let's
go to emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com from Lynn
Lindsey says hi Matt thank you for the
discussion on the survey of biologists
who nearly unanimously agree that life
begins at conception it was encouraging
to hear that that even though most of
the survey professionals were either
pro-choice non-religious or Democrat in
fact most of them were all of those
things Lindsey
they were still able to admit that life
begins at conception my worries that as
conservative pro-life movement convinces
more people of this truth there will
there will still be way too many people
who admit to this fact yet say that a
woman's right to choose is more
important societally than a preborn
infants
to life what do you think we can do
about it when hearts are that hardened
yeah well I think actually Lindsey
that's exactly the direction of the
pro-abortion movement is headed that's
the direction that it has to head that
is strategically the the smartest
direction for it to head because they
have lost the biological argument as as
science has progressed and as we've
learned more about what happens in the
womb and essentially where babies come
from and how babies come about more
specifically as we learn more and more
about that it just continues every step
every discovery just more and more of
indicates the pro-life position because
what we find is that every single
discovery confirms this fact that these
are human beings and so the pro-abortion
side has lost the loss the biological
argument the proportion argument the
biological argument for pro-abortion
people was a lot more tenable 50 years
ago 60 years ago 70 years ago it still
was not tenable it still wasn't a good
argument but it was more tenable than it
is now now it just doesn't work so as
you point out I think the the move is to
say well okay fine
it's a human being it's even a person it
doesn't matter because I'm getting
abortion because it's what I want to do
and it's my body and I can do what I
want this is the bodily autonomy
argument that's what this that's what
this is all about
so the scary thing about that argument
is that number one it requires someone -
it requires them to have morally and
spiritually descended to this state
where to the into this darkness where
they can even admit to themselves yeah
you know what an abortion is is killing
a human life and I'm okay with that
because at least when when you have a
pro-abortion person who's trying to
argue that oh it's not really a human
it's not really a person that's a bad
argument and it's bad that they're
making it but at least it shows that
they still recognize at some level that
it's wrong to kill humans and so what
they have to do to to rationalize it is
pretend that it's not really a human so
that gives you something to work with
because that shows that they still have
some moral sense within then they still
have some they still have some moral
compass a little bit they still have a
conscience and so now that gives you
something to hold on to to grasp on to
and if you can only really get them to
put their defenses down and see it for
what it is maybe you can convince them
but if someone says I don't care about
that it's just about bodily autonomy
yeah that makes a little bit more a
little bit more difficult to to deal
with and I have I'm not going to go into
a whole 30 minute think about it I could
I've talked about the bodily autonomy
our autonomy argument I've written about
it
I wrote about it in my book a few years
ago I've I've dealt with in many
different places so you could go look up
any of those places where I've talked
about it but the bodily autonomy
argument is it's not a good arguments a
stupid argument it just takes it takes a
little bit more nuance to defuse it as
you go through step by step to show that
it is a when it comes down to it still
fallacious and even with so-called
bodily autonomy you are still is still
murder you are still killing an innocent
defenseless human now if someone on the
pro-abortion side is willing to throw
all of that to the side and say fine
it's a human fine it's a person fine
bodily autonomy whatever doesn't matter
but yeah it's murder fine I don't care
if they're at that point then there is
no argument anymore you can present this
is someone who has forfeited their soul
and until they make an attempt to
reclaim it there's not much you can say
to them another way of putting it is
once a pro-abortion person is saying
that then you've won the argument even
if they don't admit it that's the
arguments over you won and that's all
case from Adam says what is your opinion
of the libertarian argument that
discrimination while ethically abhorrent
should be protected under the freedom of
association clause in the first amend
well there are a few problems with your
question Adam one problem really it
depends on what kind of discrimination
you're talking about and in what context
I don't agree that all the
discrimination should be well I don't
agree that all discrimination should be
protected under the First Amendment and
on the other hand I also don't agree
that all discrimination is ethically
abhorrent it really depends keep in mind
that discrimination is simply or can be
simply the act of choosing one thing
over another or even simply recognizing
the differences between one thing and
another it is a word related to
discernment in this context so that's
what discrimination can just be that it
can also be prejudicial treatment
against someone based on race or creed
it all depends on the context and this
is why the idea that and I I don't mean
to be to get into semantics would be or
be pedantic about it but this is really
important because you hear people say
discrimination is evil discrimination is
terrible anti discrimination all of this
stuff doesn't make any sense we all
discriminate constantly every day all
the time
and most of that discrimination is
perfectly ethical or at least morally
neutral something as simple as putting
on a red shirt rather than a white shirt
that's that's discrimination and then
there are more there are more morally
engaged forms of discrimination than
that that are still perfectly fine just
as we go through our lives right we make
decisions we choose one thing or another
we come in and that's that's all
scrimmage as for the prejudicial context
prejudicial against race or creed or
whatever I agree that it's usually
unethical but yes I do think that in the
context of to private individuals or
private entities it is protected by the
First Amendment or at least it should be
now for the state to treat people
prejudicially that is unconstitutional
that's not okay we're all guaranteed
equal treatment under the law it's a
very important guarantee that we have
and that should be enforced but if I for
example walk into a store and the owner
of the store tells me to get the hell
out because I'm not welcome there for
whatever reason my religion my race me
personally he doesn't like whatever it
is
that's discrimination I wouldn't like it
I'd probably be angry about it and
embarrassed and I would feel
inconvenienced but I think he should
have every right to do that for this
reason he owns his labor he owns his
property and to say that he must serve
me would be to violate freedom of
association freedom of speech and it
becomes a form of forced labor it is a
literally forced labor that's not an
exaggeration because this person is
being forced by law to provide me with a
good or service against his will which
is again by definition forced labor and
I think it is obviously therefore in
violation of both the letter and spirit
of the Constitution and so iiiii I think
there are exceptions you could get into
and talk about where for example it's a
matter of life and death I don't know
there aren't a lot of example you know
so for example a hospital can't turn
refused to save someone's life because
they don't like their race or creed or
whatever so that makes sense if it's
literally life or death outside of a
medical context I can't think of at
least in modern society modern American
side society I can't think of a form of
discrimination among private entities
outside of a medical context that would
put someone's life in danger I'm sure
there probably are but so I don't know
if somebody is is just stumbled out of
the desert and they're dying of thirst
and they come into your restaurant and
they they need a drink I think you
should not be able to say no because
that would be putting this person's life
in jeopardy so outside of those kinds of
scenarios I think people should it
broadly have the right to refuse service
to whoever they want
ceases from Phil says dear supreme
bearded overlord far be it for me to
refer to you as anything but flawless
but there's a problem that I must
address someone a Lackey of some sort
obviously has introduced a typo in your
end credits senior producer is
misspelled as senior Sen oh I our
producer I noticed this recently and
thought I should bring it to your
attention your lowly servant Phil Phil
rest assured that for causing me this
humiliation the person who did that typo
has been fired because I do have that
kind of authority and for pointing this
out and embarrassing me in public your
penalty upon my ascendancy to the throne
will be far worse let's just say that
there will be firing involved for you
but of a different sort and there goes
my phone whoever just called me and
embarrassed me there too that person
also will be executed and now that I
have again threatened to execute my own
viewers just a normal Friday I think we
can wrap this up for the day thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening
have a great weekend Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by associate
producer Alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we will get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there